pour faire cette vidéo j'ai fait la
compassion beaucoup avant la vidéo je
mets juste voir c'est une énigme
sur cette séquence trouver le gros
débiles qui fait des mouvements
absolument nulle et absurde ceux qui
trouvent qu'un héros une médaille
j'adore dix mille aujourd'hui en
compagnie de rouler sur games and
special disney oui je trouve que oui
cette kinect bah oui c'est ma main
gauche mais pas maintenant
oui j'aimerais de l'absence de tout le
québec
une technologie vraiment supérieur aux
autres ou la sandero d'eric roy ça ne va
pas faire les valeurs danse on veut
juste danser en fait non non non on
pense alors c'est donc ça a l'air bon
mais attendez de ces mêmes qui me fait
puisque tu veux mon pied gauche
et c'est laurent jeu contiendra c'est le
viol elle choisit quoi ce que tu vois
mais t'es ok alors aujourd'hui je trouve
actuellement pour faire une pause dans
mes révisions pour vous proposer un
avenir
et la lumière fut moi qui sait le mieux
faire le singe ici mais j'en peux plus
[Musique]
tu as même planète hall a acheté ma
première partie de gcb et bah oui bah ça
se la pète par ici bon hu a tout gratter
du coup il s'agit déjà de la conférence
et qu'il a grandi chez moi moi je
vous trouve ceinture au pénal en
comminges à qui attend ça aucune faute
ayant joie alors je compte sur toi pour
qu'on gagne sur les moines surtout avec
moi c'est bon
[Musique]
marchois stacco la plus simple de tout
d'eau d'insomnie et je me suis dit allez
porter les jambes
ben oui ça prend tout le monde mais pas
là ce week-end et on sait maintenant
devenir le grand obstacle aux mecs ils
referont pas à ce match - j'adore
[Musique]
un gros soutien côté sur l'écran mais je
ressens que ces dépenses là sans la
puissance ses dépenses et ses tours je
parle de plâtre je me rends compte
postal et ça c'était ma plainte s'était
désisté et incite à prendre des photos
parce qu'en fait des grosses offres et
la mecque de microsoft se marre en
voyant on regarde c'est le branle bas qu
il ya sept ans et demi aux diables
rouges convaincu et l'ordre des
indicateurs pour rigoler et soit
mentalement pour rigoler sur cette
musique espagnole
allez on y va on ne fait pas un petit
côté
staal a patiné lâche hathaway
mais ça petit chaperon rouge a laissé la
beauté alors est-ce que ça les espagnols
les enfants et moi je draguais me
draguer on attend on sait tous que mon
dos en boîte maintenant
[Musique]
attention ce département d'un style avec
la chanson espagnole c'est juste une
heure à toi tu vas chanter du spatial
on a trouvé dans un bar les prix de 10
euros ht
on adore dans la situation oui mais un
cauchemar à 20,89 même interne à la hâte
que ça que je vois sur la tête alors oui
on va pas te rends tu as ma coupe de
cheveux je vais préciser je ne fais
n'importe quoi
je fais d'abord de corps rocheux onex
[Musique]
et ça ça aussi c'est une microcentrale
on va laisser faire le même poste maudit
seconde monte à mater leur tête pendant
ce temps-là tu es bien se moquer d'eux
j'ai joué encore avec mon fauteuil et
jean marc gagné c'est du foutage de
gueule bon bah écoute et j'espère cette
ligue 2 aura juste un petit job days
pour la révision du bac
en tout cas en ce moment à cause d'une
nouvelle vidéo - de vie à souika tous
épisodes satio de combat et 20 tommy
castro
et moi je peux y allèrent non
connaissez-vous cette émission bien